welcome back to our big birthday bash
well you know what that sound is it's
giveaway time more birthday gifts for
the birthday gang and first up my flower
beauty petal pout lip scrub and lip mask
in the shade
barrymore
i scrub and mask with this all the time
i'm giving this away with total
confidence that it's going to make you
guys happy and that's so important to me
to have your back you'll never go to the
bathroom and go
my lipstick
not on my watch
and uh where is jessica cantu by the way
surprise
hello um we heard that you have been on
a weight loss journey yes drew i am i've
been working two jobs for about uh three
years now and so i saved up money i took
out a small loan emptied my savings
account and i paid to have my gastric
sleeve surgery in may 2021 and i've lost
115 pounds since then
well you're an inspiration and um to
keep up with the momentum and add to
your routine we have the new hydro rower
exercise machine plus a year-long access
membership and this package is valued at
over 2 500
and this is all the rage in exercise
right now because it's like such a full
body workout
[Music]